[Music]
oh
the village is depending on us to go get
our food for the hard to get food out
here
okay
that was a battle
yeah we're gonna try to go out in the
boat and see if we can catch a game
whatever uh we're running too
whatever
opportunity comes up we'll we'll take
wait for ola
ah you're back
taking Chris and Allah with me today so
hopefully uh we'll get something out
there
we're all good out there
I promise you
[Music]
there's been no uh walrus for the past
couple months slow season this year
all our fish are red cake
go on the ocean Arrow
I'm a provider Italian food for family
and friends
keeping this Village alive
we can't come home empty-handed
there's no water right on the other side
of this ice look like it's opening up so
the curtain might have uh just shifted
window of opportunity
yeah I even worse
hanging out just swimming around no
there huh yeah
guys he's opening up right there moving
oh there'll be more game out there but
we don't know how long that current is
going to be some days it'll be cut
shorts by a couple hours super
you gotta watch that real real close or
ice make Frozen on us
the stick water right here has game
instead plan ahead and think about
tomorrow think about next year's think
about next month think about what you're
gonna do
you can't just deal with your living
life day to day
I'll show you guys how to drop these
trees okay this is where her hand is
going to be
all right and then you bend your knee
you rest this arm on this one
chainsaw is going to go flat
and we'll come through and do the back
cut all right okay
Evan you'll be a spider for Terrence
you're gonna cut first okay now I'm
going to be right there with you
this Wood Yard it was given to me by my
uncle Charlie you know a family needs a
Woodyard out here without a wood yard
got no way to get any wood so just
woodlot it's been in our family for a
while now you know that's how these
things go along come here Terry okay
they get passed down from generations to
generation okay go ahead
Terence he's a very strong he's very
smart
and I show them stuff I don't have to go
over it over it over it
that's good
he's able to pick up on stuff a lot
faster than I was able to when is his
age keep going
foreign
nice all right let's check it out all
right look at that boy that's perfect
that is absolutely perfect
she says it is an absolute perfect pie
cut now for our second back cut we're
going to come in about a half inch to an
inch higher flat straight the bike cut
is like a
I couldn't apply
the back
in the chainsaw
so
[Music]
Drop It Like It's Hot huh
right now we're just trying to build
them up and get their confidence out
there in the woods get them confident
run the chainsaw stuff that these boys
are going to have to learn and do all
their life
every day I see a little Improvement in
their strength and their conditioning
their mind and soul they're getting
stronger you're better every day very
proud of you
yeah high five
[Music]
yeah look at that
oh that's nice that's an absolute
perfect cut you did proud of you good
job boy
good job hollering that was fun man this
is whoo man I've been doing this out
here in the Woodyard by myself for how
many years boring you know this is fun
with you guys out here been missing out
man all right boys let's get these limbs
off this tree get it limited up three of
us together shouldn't take very long
we are how are you here in the village
we have a lot of good history and
culture it's great being Alaska native
you bring your bait
can't speed up fresh salmon this time of
the year
Justin and I we're gonna go out and do a
little bit of trolling are you ready
yeah all right buddy
what we are fishing for is King and they
are year round I figured we'll go out
there and give it a shot because last
year I think it was about this time of
the year he caught one so we wanted to
go and try his honey hole out again
nice over there nice looking weather
we got the ice out here huh should be
good enough to start here there's the
honey hole here huh all right
all right here we are controlling is
when you just tow a hook behind your
skiff
used to be that's just what the Kings
love
okay ready to start fishing okay
if you can
pick up some fish and see if they've
come up and bite
150 feet deep so we can go a lot deeper
but we're good right now
we've really had one before in this
neighborhood yep just right out here it
was right at the switch of Tide wind
started picking up just like this
it takes time for trolling you to be out
there for two three hours you know it's
a matter of just sitting there and
waiting for them to buy it would be nice
to get out like I say you know the long
nights if I was to come to the shoulder
and the days are getting longer
to get out beautiful weather see
different things
good to get out from Cabin Fever
you might hear me say like yeah we live
off the land but really we live with it
because so much of what we do is also
caring for the land
the land sustains us and we care for and
respect the land and all that it carries
whenever I'm out on the land no matter
what I'm doing you know hunting I could
be running dogs I'm always looking for
tracks of any other animals rabbit
tracks especially this time of year I'm
always looking for a good place to set
snares right here's good
they see fresh rabbit tracks on this
Rabbit Trail
it looks pretty well used so this is a
good spot to set some snares
fire
to make my snares near the fire because
my hands will get really cold and 40
below and that can be kind of dangerous
might be enough
[Music]
when you're out on the land and these
really bitter cold temperatures you just
have to really play it safe and carry
all your safety equipment you know I
always have my matches and Fire Starter
on me so I caught my kids
see my hands are already getting a
little cold so it is really important to
be able to
know how to make a good quick fire
out here
doesn't even need to be very big
[Music]
so you don't need a lot for rabbit
snaring
I actually keep some wire in my pocket
I'm trying to make a loop with this wire
that I'll be able to hang over a rabbit
Trail you've got to be about the size of
your fist which is about the size of a
rabbit's head
gonna go through here it's gonna pull
the wire like that that's how I catch
the rabbit
well I warmed up my hands and
my snares are ready
it's the fun part
in Alaska you have to do things in 40
below without your gloves on
I'm gonna set this snare above the
Rabbit Trail
so the rabbit's gonna come hopping
through here
and then
so yeah I learned this from my mom I
taught my kids and when my kids were
little they had their little rabbits and
Airlines and they'd come home
just happy carrying their rabbits
hopefully a rabbit will come hopping
through and then we'll have dinner
I'm gonna just keep looking for really
good rabbit trails to set more snares
today
we have to hunt in order to eat to
survive for the next day
all right
this water has game
of walrus isn't that crack of War
over there
it was going south towards trying to
watch those work to come on over here
just in case a little passage but
smaller on us got to watch the current
foreign
[Music]
I don't know a good one
is
yeah
so far we've only seen uh walrus in the
water
nothing on the ice
the bull walrus are hard to too
stay under longer and it can go further
all right
here
[Music]
topped it up a little bit too much from
this ice
[Music]
for the board up here yeah
thank you
all right there they're nice right there
gotta take it off
another one
[Music]
ah
current uh has shifted okay let's go
you're coming in so we gotta go in fast
starting to close up a little bit right
now so we gotta go up to the launch
the ice closes in on you out there
you'll be in a bad spot
it's been days out there a couple of
nights go back on the other side of this
one huh
one time we had 11 boats out there stuck
because of the ice trying to keep warm
is hard out there covered in ice we get
frostbitten
dangerous out there we've had to wait
till next morning to come home
made it through a little opening
we got lucky
and we gotta wait for another day to
clean it up and uh do some hunting if we
don't catch any walls how are you gonna
eat
being out here on this land practicing
my traditional way of life is really
where I find peace and Solitude and joy
in my heart that I can't really find
anywhere else
[Music]
well I have let my snares set overnight
so I'm here to
check them and see if I
got anything
[Music]
well nothing in this snare
no new tracks or anything it doesn't
snare is undisturbed I'll just leave it
and
check the rest of my snares see if I
have any left
[Music]
when I was a little girl checking my
rabbit snares I was always really
excited and I think I would run the
majority of the way to my first snare
still kind of feel that sense of
excitement going out to check my snares
today even as an adult
snare is gone
the stick was secured there so I caught
something now I gotta kind of track
where it might have gone
because those tracks are new right here
so it took my stick with the snare on it
never had that really happen before
I see Fresh Tracks right here and then
that stick that I had the snare secured
to here here here and it's popping
around and making imprints in the snow
like that
all right
the rabbit tracks just go up here around
this big tree but I thought it might be
close up here but I see its tracks
continuing further back in the woods so
I'm going to put on my snowshoes it's
just too deep of snow to walk through
oh he got away
walk away like you have to just go after
it
we have that responsibility to the
animal
you know I respect it for giving itself
now I gotta go find it make use of it
[Music]
when you're out in the water you know if
you can hear the birds see the wildlife
I love this place here
we'll go check that spot out right there
is that where we want to go or yeah just
start from over there and look the way
over that eagle there waiting to get a
duck yeah he's watching What I've Done
big mature Baldy the weather is flat
calm sun is out and we are going to this
other spot that Justin likes to check
now it's a matter of putting the
patients to the test
there's a sea lion's head right there
yep there's a question five of them yeah
it's pretty cool
hahaha
[Music]
there they are poor fishing
that's a hell of a deal that was all
right to see
Oh What a Beautiful Day
[Music]
come on
King
halibut it'd be nice to get a halibut
even a black bass would be nice
as a kid growing up there was a lot of
fish back in the day
[Music]
now we gotta go farther away to get our
salmon
[Music]
the fish is not there like it used to be
I look at it as the management we've got
crawlers up and down our Bay here
nobody talks about controlling industry
around how it destroyed halibut king
crab
habitat for all the bottom fish
and it's not going to take very much
more to deplete what we got
it's got a little fight to it whatever
he is
got your landing net ready I'll get her
as soon as I get this out of the road
here buddy
feels pretty tingy like
because there's much tension on it yeah
so it has no chance to really Translate
okay 30 feet oh
[Music]
okay here he's coming up get the head in
there turn inside nice
[Music]
think of that huh that's a cool one but
it's a nailed one this is the same exact
setup that I caught my first one on but
he made my day no crap man king salmon
buddy yeah it's all right in there you
can see underneath the skill plate you
can see that red meat that's a good sign
that is a good red meat King not a white
if it was all white meat like a halibut
then there'd be a white king because
they're a lot oilier
as soon as I felt him peel and drag
that's a good sign of either a halibut
or a king usually caught or Pollock Bass
good cat mission accomplished there
buddy yep time to head on
there's my family inside my house and it
goes to the community the whole kaiku
river you know we're all just one big
strong family
[Music]
I believe in you oven
hang on tight to the chainsaw and listen
to Jack also listen to me nice safe
balloon okay
good boys thank you what time you guys
are young man you'll be able to build
build your own house unless you go to
college you make good money and then you
can buy a house but ain't nothing ever
going to feel better than coming out
getting these trees yourself and
building your own house you know
all right let's do this
I didn't wake up and know all this stuff
one day you know I learned from
everybody all right I lined you up my
father my grandfather
for my children you know I want them to
be able to live out here in the woods
okay
but if life took them to the city and
they ended up living in the city I want
them to be able to thrive wherever they
end up in life
I just want them to be able to do the
best that they can to be successful
[Music]
be careful with that chainsaws
all right see yeah it looks good good
stuff for your first try
get onto it tight
[Music]
when my son Evan was born doctors told
us that he was sick and that he wasn't
going to make it very long
maybe a few months if that the living
be able to see my son out here is a big
powerful strong guy not a sickness in
his body I'm amazed and I'm very proud
of you
[Music]
oh
I adore every minute I would share with
my boys
sometimes I wake up and I just feel
lucky
[Music]
alright so let's get this one limbed up
we'll Buck them up eight foot all right
boys this is what we do
[Music]
I want a strong healthy family
we came from strong healthy people I
don't want that to end with me
all right good job boys
go home and
see how proud your mama is or her big
boys I swear man it was just yesterday's
catching you guys coming out from Mama
now I'm watching you boys Drop trees in
Hollywood and helping me
time flies by real fast boom let's go
ahead and get this trapped down and head
home
and we'll come back for some more
I think everything that we have is
gifted from creator
you know the land provides for us so we
have to care for the land in return
getting really kind of hard to walk
around here
I'm still following these rabbit tracks
we've kind of made it like halfway up a
mountain
I'm gonna ditch my snowshoes and go by a
foot
[Music]
I'm starting to say Predator sign like
it's been sort of nicely clawed animal
following the rabbit track
over here looks like Predator claws
I gotta keep going before it gets dark
well it went this way
oh man
ICS tracks including the stick going
down this way and it's pretty thick in
there so I'm hoping it finally got
stopped up
I wish I had a sled right now
I'm glad to see I'm still on this Trail
looks like something went down into this
hole
[Music]
I don't see anything
it's that rabbit just disappeared down
here I
can't believe this
[Music]
I don't like doing that to animals so I
feel pretty bad
but I'm going to keep going there's a
few tracks down here I don't know if
it's my rabbit I mean they ended here so
I see something down there I'm gonna go
check it out
[Music]
you know I may be a hunter but you know
these animals we take for a purpose and
it's just super important out here to
treat those animals with respect
it's kind of a bad look for me that's
not a good way to
treat our brothers and sisters on this
land
put in really good effort followed that
rabbit until I lost this Trail
completely
I feel bad so I'm just ready to go home
be a good Hunter and gatherer be
successful and if not just overcome and
believe you're gonna do it the next time
pretty heavy huh it's a nice thick
fish there buddy
all right they're cool like that
it's like the fish I can cook that Yeti
I don't know I was thinking of my
barbecue it
or deep fry it maybe a little bit of
both that load is a 100 meal
the reward is going to be greater now
that we got it and Justin's a good cook
at the end of the day when you got that
all cooked a little bit of snow was no
problem didn't take no time but all the
reward is when we get to sit down and
eat with the family and have all the
good tree trough your Harvest yourself
yeah
[Music]
yeah I'm ready
all the native food like seal fish
everything that we eat these babies eat
happy to see that
fish was so good your dad caught
I've known with the harshness of this
country from learning from our elders
and our ancestors we learned how to make
this a habitable country
yes
is the biggest one we've got in The Wood
Yard right here
how you guys feel about taking turns and
helping cut it this would be fun
dude this is a family we'll get this
down together
[Music]
confidence in a young man you know
cheers you know just going out and doing
these types of work with me seeing me do
it and accomplish it
that's an old and that's for sure been
here before us before my parents how
long you think it's been here probably a
century you never know who can even put
your arms around it can I give it a hug
and goodbye
goodbye welcome it to our new addition
on to the hose yep it's gonna be part of
our family now yeah it's gonna be a good
host
I'll get it done
some good yeah all right
foreign
[Music]
I do a lot of this stuff on my soul
you know that I brought a mochair and
I'm seeing my boys Drop trees
oh this is amazing it's opened up a
whole new world to me
[Music]
oh
it's not on it ever
now I know it's a lot of fun having my
sons with me
all right not too much now we're getting
close
it's been so many years learning and now
it's time for me to take all this
knowledge that I spent learning and pass
it on to my children
[Music]
all right you guys heads up now bringing
it down
[Music]
[Applause]
three of us got this down no problem
exactly where we wanted to go you guys
see you listen to me you guys watch what
I do you guys learn this stuff you guys
want to be dropping trees no time before
we know it we'll be sending you out on
your own you boys go get us some wood
all right boys let's get it limbed up
it's a learning experience for all of us
here
learning their capabilities and their
limits and they're definitely
surprisingly they're stronger than I
thought they were they're tough kids
I got it marched out at a 10 foot right
here
we're gonna get a lot out of this one
tree anything that's not usable going
through the wood stove you know so we're
gonna use everything
[Music]
this is just the start of it eventually
we're going to start building houses and
cabins and getting a lot done out here
in the woods
[Music]
I've been waiting years and years
couldn't wait until my two sons were old
enough to be able to turn the woods
hopefully
[Music]
all right I think we're set boys
I don't think ain't no kids your age
ever drop a tree like this
had a lot of men my age probably ain't
never dropped the tree that big
you guys did good today man proud of you
boys
being on the Yukon I feel closest to my
ancestors our way of life and culture
and also my identity
there's a lot of important values and
lessons and the way that we live
well I feel pretty bummed out my spirit
is down because I made a mistake and
caught some animals some suffering so I
just feel really bad about it
[Music]
so I'm just gonna smudge and try to you
know re-center myself
[Music]
indigenous people practice smudging when
we pray
I think prayer is just so important no
matter what your belief is and where you
come from creators always listening
[Music]
we use the animals for a purpose you
know to feed our families and you know
it's in our culture to really take care
of those animals too
I feel like I failed
I think there's things that we can
always learn from mistakes
this is something that I won't ever
forget
so when I have grandkids and we teach
them how to set snares like this will be
important part of their lesson
to move forward in the best way that I
can
[Music]
assistance is very important out here in
a village
everybody is depending on each other
that's the only way we survive out here
yesterday there's lots of walrus nearby
looking out on the binocular so
let's go check it out
catching sea mammals is our way of life
been like this for hundreds of years
while we're from Texas
Big Bowl
yeah there's a bit too much fat guys
that's the current change on if it's
just the dice will open up and we still
got a chance to get to that walrus
we've seen a couple of wars in the water
so how many of them like three of them
in there they can stay under quite a bit
the bull walls can stay under more than
half hour sometimes
oh
[Music]
barely missed it
always hurt a come back out again
come on
[Music]
look Baltimore
the right side
foreign
missed
okay you know you've got to be a very
precise in your harpooning it's a lot of
pressure at times there's a lot of
people relying on you family members
pretty much the whole village
gotta make sure you know you finish it
off good
damn
that will come back up
hey
foreign
okay
if you have a walrus on a harpoon line
you've got to be very cautious that the
walrus come back alive and start pulling
I've heard of uh one person losing a
finger he didn't know it he didn't even
feel one of his brothers seen it you
know hey your thumb is gone yeah
two three
okay just need to get today
[Music]
almost there
huh
[Music]
we're gonna tie it up
a god
thank God
no we're talking
all right
a big bull eat everybody in the village
or Spoon Man
we're gonna be Towing this walrus hole
we're gonna pull it up
we're gonna work on it hopefully
a bunch of people come out to uh get a
taste
eat something fresh
[Music]
amazes meal right now a lot of people
come down to the beach to see the
animals that we bring home for uh food
so
[Music]
we're gonna pull the water
or something all these people
everybody roll
oh
[Music]
here we go
that's a lot of food
everybody's there at the beach they're
taking home what they can
pick up makes me happy that they come
down and get a Sheriff from the walrus
and you know it makes me happy
you know it's a been a very slow season
this year that's the first wall
I know there don't have too much food in
their feet here
you know helping each other out carrying
on the Epic tradition been going on for
Generations
that's who we are
it's what we eat it's what do we do
gotta give it back to Mother Nature
it gave itself up to his food in respect
you're giving it back
so that's what I'm trying to follow in
my heart
all of our individual tribes we have
values that we live by that really lead
us in life
I was brought up on respecting our land
sharing has been taught to us since we
were little it's passed on throughout
each generation
there's no greater way to honor your
elders than live in a traditional
lifestyle though to respecting the land
respecting the animals the way they
taught us
feel better and everybody's eating
this uh we have life I hope it goes on
forever
[Music]